iphone versus android
which is better
[Applause]
whoa hold up just wait before you write
something dogmatic in the comment
section supporting your team this video
is not about which mobile os is better
let's face it in terms of functionality
both camps have their pros and cons the
things that matter for me and if you're
watching some sub for you too are
privacy and security
so that's why today we're going to try
and understand which ecosystem brings
you a more secure digital jungle ios or
android it's me bradley and this
all right some sub
let's get into it
[Music]
according to a survey conducted in
february 2021 46 of participants stated
that on average they spend five to six
hours on their phone on a daily basis oh
dear that means that for almost half of
you a quarter of your life security will
be dictated by your choice of mobile
platform but how safe are these popular
phone platforms anyway because mobile
devices have grown to be so important
and pervasive in people's lives they
have piqued the interest of criminal
hackers looking to steal your personal
information so security and
understanding it is paramount the
technology itself is always advancing
and that's why i'm not going to compare
specific android or ios versions but
rather the core principles and
philosophy behind the brand apple and
the rest which importantly have
consequences in terms of privacy and
security as you know there are many
smartphone manufacturers that choose
android as their os of choice
the security and privacy implementations
vary from huawei where the best of your
photos will be reviewed by the chinese
communist party and delivered to uncle c
in an envelope to the most secure for
instance graphene os now in this video i
compare google's implementation of this
os as it is on for example google pixel
phones
usually when it comes to downloading an
app there is only one popular way to do
so through a dedicated store for example
google play or the app store on both
platforms the submitted application will
then go through an app review process to
ensure that it's not malicious and also
doesn't violate any of the developer
policies these regulations primarily aim
to ensure that the app's content is
appropriate and that it doesn't imitate
other apps or individuals that it
adheres to the monetization policies and
guidelines and it observes the main bare
minimum functionality requirements i
mean for instance it shouldn't crash all
the time and it should certainly respect
the user experience the issue is that
those who examine whether apps adhere to
certain criteria may not actually be
aware of what the app does with personal
information
the number of apps for both android and
ios as well as their developers is
constantly increasing and companies have
actually had to hire more reviewers in
recent years as a result
we all know what happens when a company
hires thousands of employees at once
it's difficult to scale the learning
management system and not all employees
will be trained properly as a result the
biggest difference in approach as far as
we know now is that apple has real
people reviewing each app 100 of the
time while google tries to automate this
process as much as they can and it
creates problems for them time and time
again a study released in november of
2020 by the norton lifelock research
group revealed that among 34 million
apps spread across 12 million android
devices
between 10 and 24 could be described as
malicious or potentially unwanted
applications depending on different
classifications of those applications 67
were installed from the google play
store the has mentioned that the play
market is the main app distribution
vector responsible for 87 of all
installs and 67 of all unwanted installs
this means that significant amounts of
unwanted apps are able to bypass the
android security measures now this makes
well google play store the main
distribution vector for unwanted apps so
if you're that person that downloads
tons of apps searching for the perfect
one consider deleting the few underdogs
the fewer apps you have on your phone
the better in my opinion the truth
it's not the one now in the end users
are more likely to install malware by
downloading it from web pages by their
device browsers or from alternative
marketplaces and this is once again a
big problem with android and its ability
to side load apps so here i have no
other choice than giving one point
to apple and this is not because of how
good their security is but more about
well the unpredictable wild west that
the android ecosystem seems to imitate
everything out here that's not you wants
to kill you
[Music]
from controlling the way apps appear on
your phone the biggest threat to mobile
security is apps that basically ask for
too many access rights and then they use
those access rights to leak your data
while the bulletproof safe that is the
app store is mostly responsible for
keeping out the kind of malware riffraff
that affects disproportionate number of
android users iphone owners are not
immune to attacks what i mean here is
the following ios users feel safe but
they're not the horrifying fact is that
no one is safe
either in the plains above dulles or in
the terminal below first and foremost
when an app gets access to for example
all photos normally people understand
that the app can actually load all of
your photos in the background use
machine learning to detect not safe for
work content and then upload it quietly
to a server and when the app does that
you won't get that neat camera access
dot in the corner moreover even if you
block all permissions for the app
there's still a variety of data that can
actually be collected and tracked
nevertheless
according to an investigation by
researchers at privacy software maker
lockdown and the washington post
every app can track 29 very specific
data points about your iphone including
your ip address your free storage your
current volume level by the way that's
to three decimal points leaving your
battery level to 15 decimal points you'd
think that such data is pretty useless
right but do you remember i told you
about digital fingerprints in one of our
last videos your iphone's device
fingerprint could have been listed for
sale on that website now you maybe
didn't even know that your device had
one of these fingerprints yep it's there
up for sale on the dark web well if you
don't trust me here's how washington
post puts it it's the kind of unique
data that could be used by advertisers
to identify your iphone possibly letting
them know what other apps you use or how
to target you in other words it's
sidestepping your request to be left
alone you can't stop it what about
android well i've got no good news for
its users either research that was
conducted by douglas lathe from trinity
college dublin suggests google collects
more than 20 times more data from a
typical android handset than apple does
from a typical iphone even when a user
has explicitly opted out of telemetry
gathering this finding still holds true
both android and ios handsets share data
with google and apple servers every 4.5
minutes on average and there's nothing
you can do about it as a user
researchers also noted that devices on
default privacy settings share
information related to the imei sim
serial number phone number hardware
serial number location cookies local ip
address nearby wi-fi mac addresses and
even the advertising id
by the way both companies disagree with
the findings noting that they only
reveal what's necessary to keep phones
running smoothly
well that's not really the first time
we're hearing about selling our privacy
for convenience is it
so a couple things one privacy i think
is too small a term i use it today
because that's what people respond to
but i think it's personal security like
where i am is a personal security matter
or it's financial security amazon just
introduced their new amazon key service
which will allow their delivery people
to physically
enter your home so the next time your
phone's battery is being drained by some
unknown app running in the background
there's a good chance that's just your
phone sending these photos you forgot
about to the mother ship still in a
recent blog post android pledged to roll
out new rules starting in december 2021
that would by default lock out any
permissions for apps that haven't been
used in a while this feature helps
protect user privacy by automatically
resetting an app's runtime permissions
if the app hasn't been used for a while
let's say a few months i think that this
move is very important and especially
considering the data that we're going to
talk about next so that's why i'd like
to support google in this great idea by
giving them a point in this category
what on google
[Music]
the easiest way to secure your phone is
by keeping its os up to date updates
help to mitigate software
vulnerabilities which are usually a
security hole or weakness found in an
operating system hackers exploit this
weakness by writing code to target a
specific vulnerability which is most
often packaged into malware
these exploits can infect your
smartphone just by viewing a website
opening a compromised message or playing
infected media this is exactly what
happened with 300 000 android users bank
credentials which have been compromised
through ordinary apps on the google play
store updates are great until everything
goes terribly wrong there are tons of
stories which back this up just read the
story of armor 7611. yesterday morning i
got a notification from the android 11
software update and it says the update
went through got 100 restarted went
through optimizing app x of x x
and then never got past the verizon
loading screen now i'm not saying that
sort of stuff happens a lot but it
happens much more on android phones so
when it comes to sending updates to your
palm apple still has the production
chain carry network contacts and
underlying code in place to make all of
that happen swiftly and without pain on
the user's side while some customers
continue to bemoan ios's infamous lack
of personalization apple's well-released
walled garden has a guarantee that
iphone owners are virtually immune to
malware without even having to think
about it google on the other hand still
can't fix the android update problem you
see each smartphone running android uses
different hardware so when an update
gets pushed to it by google it sometimes
takes almost a year for other smartphone
manufacturers to update their devices
that's only if they plan to update them
you see apart from the google pixel line
other android phones rarely get updates
for a long time and there are several
reasons why the first thing to consider
is how many different models each
manufacturer offers every year apple
only adds a maximum of around four
iphones to its lineup so cumulatively
the number of ios devices it needs to
support is relatively low this isn't the
case with android where you have a
myriad of different manufacturers all
manufacturing endless different products
each year and that all is flooding the
market with new devices that all require
dedicated maintenance as a result of all
of this some firms will frequently
prioritize their flagship products while
the less expensive variants will
frequently be overlooked considering all
of that i'd like to give
one point to ios
[Music]
the most important difference in terms
of security and safety between ios and
android lies in their philosophy ios is
a closed ecosystem thus when it comes to
security it's 100 in the hands of apple
the point there is that as far as we
know apple doesn't make any money from
ads apart from advertising apps in the
app store thus it's not that interested
in collecting and sharing your data with
third parties that however won't stop
intruders hacking your icloud if you
haven't set up two-factor authentication
for instance remember what happened to
all those celebrities about seven years
ago you sure that will never happen to
you
google on the other hand makes most of
its money from ads this means their
business relies on the ability to target
their ads as well as they possibly can
even android is an open source project
google play services which collect the
data are not also even though android
provides weaker safety out of the box
some android builds may actually provide
an extreme level of security so this is
also something to bear in mind so what
should be the final takeaway well i
guess no matter what os you're using
most of the vulnerabilities are more to
do with social engineering and our
inadvertence rather than software or
hardware reports by cyber security firms
lookout and verizon showed a 37 increase
in enterprise mobile phishing attacks
last year and most importantly those
phishing attacks were the top cause of
data breaches globally in 2020. now i
bet the data is going to be quite
similar of 2021. please share your
stories of mobile hex that you've lived
through in the comments below i bet
you've all got great stories to tell so
my name is bradley peake and i'd like to
thank you personally for joining me on
another glorious glistening gentlemanly
glide above the grey green canopies of
the online jungle
and remember there's always one way that
you can be totally sure in your online
safety and that is switching this button
right here
see you in the next video
[Music]
you